okay
[Music]
their excellencies the bilateral chief
submission joined by acting dean of the
difficult diplomatic war
his excellency solemn
[Music]
so
my
[Music]
sorry
ladies and gentlemen please direct your
attention toward the inaugural platform
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff general mark hayes
[Music]
i'm standing here
[Music]
times
[Music]
um
uh
[Music]
here
ladies and gentlemen leadership of the
united states house of representatives
the republican weapon the honorable
stephen scalise and majority web
the honorable james e clyden
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sir
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
[Music]
so
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen leadership of the
united states
senate president pro tempore emeritus
the honorable patrick leahy and mrs
marcel leahy
democratic whip the honorable dick
durbin and mrs riemann dot
majority whip the honorable john thune
and mrs kimberly thune
democratic leader the honorable charles
schumer and mrs irish weinshall schumer
and president pro-tempore of the senate
the honorable chuck grassley
and mrs jennifer hines
[Music]
oh my gosh it's going to be cold
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen former vice
president the honorable dan
quayle
[Music]
it
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
this
i think
[Music]
[Applause]
sir
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the 42nd president
of the united states
the honorable william j clinton and the
honorable hillary rodham clinton
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the 43rd president
of the united states
the honorable george w bush and mrs
laura bush
[Music]
thank
[Music]
um
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the 44th president
of the united states
the honorable barack h obama and mrs
michelle obama
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the chief justice
of the united states
the honorable john g roberts jr and the
associate justices of the supreme court
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
ladies and gentlemen the children of
vice president-elect harris
and mr douglas impov cole macken imhoff
and ella rose imhoff
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
just
[Music]
few
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
it's really cool
[Music]
siri
so
all right
yes
ladies and gentlemen the children of the
president-elect
robert hunter biden ii have actually
been blazer fight
also the grandchildren
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
choke
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen accompanying the
vice president the secretary of the
senate
the honorable julie e adams and chief
administrative officer of the house of
representatives
catherine spindor
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the vice president
of the united states
the honorable michael r pence and mrs
karen pence
[Music]
ready
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
therefore
thank you
[Music]
truck
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
retirement
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
third
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen accompanying the
vice president-elect
the chief of inaugural ceremonies maria
miller-lohmeyer
the acting deputy house sergeant-at-arms
kevin grubbs
and the acting deputy senate
sergeant-at-arms united states capitol
police officer private first class
eugene o goodman
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the vice
president-elect of the united states
kamala devi harris
and mr douglas imhoff
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the joint congressional committee on
inaugural ceremonies staff
representative alexandria gordikan
dico accompanying the house republican
leader the honorable kevin mccarthy
staff representative bridget brennan
accompanying house majority leader
the honorable steny hoyer and mrs yvette
lewis
staff representative kate knudsen
accompanying speaker of the house of
representatives the honorable nancy
pelosi and mr paul pelosi
staff representative lindsey kerr
accompanying the honorable amy klobuchar
and mr john bessler staff representative
stephanie hager
mucko accompanying senate majority
leader the honorable mitch mcconnell
and the honorable elaine l chao and
staff representative
ready face
[Music]
forward
ladies and gentlemen accompanying the
president-elect the staff director of
the joint congressional committee and
inaugural ceremonies
fits you elder iv the acting house
senate sergeant-at-arms
tim blodgett and the acting senate
sergeant-at-arms jennifer hemingway
[Music]
so
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the president-elect
of the united states
joseph robinette biden jr and dr jill
[Applause]
[Music]
biden
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen please be seated
please welcome the honorable amy
[Applause]
klobuchar
vice president pence mr president-elect
madam vice president-elect members of
congress and the judicial branch
former presidents and first ladies vice
presidents leaders from abroad
and a whole bunch of bidens america
welcome to the 59th presidential
inauguration
where in just a few moments joe biden
and kamala harris
will take their solemn oaths
this ceremony is the culmination of
244 years of a democracy
it is the moment when leaders brought to
this stage by the will of the people
promised to be faithful
to our constitution to cherish it and
defend it
it is the moment when they become as we
all should be
guardians of our country have we become
too
jaded too accustomed to the ritual of
the passing of the torch of democracy
to truly appreciate what a blessing
and a privilege it is to witness this
moment
i think not two weeks ago
when an angry violent mob stage in
insurrection
and desecrated this temple of our
democracy
it awakened us to our responsibilities
as americans this is the day
when our democracy picks itself up
brushes off the dust
and does what america always does
goes forward as a nation under god
indivisible
with liberty and justice for all
[Music]
this conveyance of a sacred trust
between our leaders and our people
takes place in front of this shining
capital dome
for a reason when abraham lincoln gave
his first inaugural address
in front of this capitol the dome was
only partially constructed braced by
ropes of steel
he promised he would finish it he was
criticized for spending
funds on it during the civil war to
those critics he replied
if the people see the capital going on
it is a sign we intend the union
shall go on and it did
and it will generations of americans
gave their lives to preserve our
republic in this place
great legislation to protect civil
rights and economic security
and lead the world was debated and
crafted
under this dome now it falls on all of
us
not just the two leaders we are
inaugurating today to take
up the torch of our democracy not as a
weapon
of political arson but as an instrument
for good
we pledge today never to take our
democracy for granted
as we celebrate its remarkable strength
we celebrate its resilience
its grit we celebrate the ordinary
people doing extraordinary things for
our nation
the doctors and nurses on the front line
of this pandemic
the officers in the capitol a new
generation never giving up hope for
justice
we celebrate a new president joe biden
who vows to restore the soul of america
and cross the river of our divides to a
higher plane
and we celebrate our first african
american first asian american
and first woman vice president
kamala harris who stands on the
shoulders of so many on this platform
who have forged the way to this day
when she takes the oath of office little
girls and boys across the world will
know that anything
and everything is possible and in the
end
that is america our democracy
a country of so much good and today
on these capital steps and before
this glorious field of flags we
rededicate
ourselves to its cause
thank you
it is now my honor to
introduce to you the senator who has
worked with me and so
many others to make this ceremony
possible
my friend and the chair of the inaugural
committee
missouri senator roy blunt
[Applause]
well i should have known when senator
klobuchar got involved at least there'd
be a touch of snow
up here this morning of all the things
we'd considered
i don't think snow was on my agenda
until i walked out the door
a moment ago but thank you senator
klobuchar and thanks to the other
members
of the joint congressional committee on
the inauguration as we
officially begin the 59th inaugural
ceremony i also want to thank the joint
committee staff and our partners
particularly our security partners
for the they the way they've dealt with
unprecedented
circumstances when i chaired the
inauguration four years ago i shared
president reagan's
1981 description of this event
as commonplace and miraculous
commonplace because we've done it every
four years since
1789 miraculous because we've done it
every four years since 1789.
americans have celebrated this moment
during war
during depression and now during
pandemic
once again all three branches of our
government come together as the
constitution envisions
once again we renew our commitment
to our determined democracy forging a
more perfect union
that theme for this inauguration our
determined
democracy forging a more perfect union
was announced by the joint committee
before the election
with the belief that the united states
can only fulfill its promise
and set an example for others if we are
always working
to be better than we have been
the constitution established that
determined democracy with its first
three words
declaring the people as the source of
the government
the articles of confederation hadn't
done that the magna carta hadn't done
that
only the constitution says the
government exists
because the people are the source of the
reason
it exists they immediately followed
those first three words
with the words to form a more perfect
union
the founders did not say to form a
perfect union
they did not claim that in our new
country nothing would need to be
improved fortunately they understood
that
always working to be better would be the
hallmark
of a great democracy the freedoms we
have today
the nation we have today
is not here just because it happened
uh and they aren't complete a great
democracy
working through the successes and
failures of our history
striving to be better than it had been
and we are more than we have been and we
are
less than we hope to be the assault on
our capital at this very place just two
weeks ago
reminds us that a government designed to
balance and check itself
is both fragile and resilient
during the last year the pandemic
challenged our free and open society and
called for extraordinary determination
and sacrifice and still challenges us
today
meeting that challenge head on have been
and our health care workers scientists
first responders essential frontline
workers
and so many others we depend on in so
many ways
today we come to this moment people all
over the world
as we're here are watching and we'll
watch what we do
here our government comes together
the congress and the courts join the
transition of executive responsibility
one political party more pleased today
and on every
inaugural day than the other but this is
not a moment of division it's a moment
of unification
a new administration begins and brings
with it a new beginning
and with that our great national debate
goes forward
and a determined democracy will continue
to be
essential in pursuit of a more perfect
union
and a better future for all americans
what a privilege for me to join you
today thank you
i'm pleased to call to the podium a long
time friend of the president-elect and
his family father leo
o'donovan to lead us in an invocation
please stand if you are able and remain
standing for the national anthem
and the pledge to our flag
thank you
gracious and merciful god
at this sacred time we come before you
in need
indeed on our knees
but we come still more with hope and
with our
eyes raised anew to the vision of a more
perfect
union in our land a union of all
our citizens to promote the general
welfare
and secure the blessings of liberty to
ourselves
and our posterity we are a people
of many races creeds and colors
national backgrounds cultures and styles
now far more numerous and on land much
vaster
than when archbishop john carroll wrote
his prayer
for the inauguration of george
washington
232 years ago
archbishop carol prayed that you
o creator of all would assist with your
holy spirit of counsel
and fortitude the president of these
united states that his administration
may be conducted in righteousness and be
eminently useful
to your people today we confess
our past failures to live according to
our vision
of equality inclusion and freedom for
all
yet we resolutely commit still more now
to renewing the vision
to caring for one another in word and
deed
especially the least fortunate among us
and so becoming a light for the world
there is a power in each and every one
of us that lives
by turning to every other one of us a
thrust of the spirit to cherish
and care and stand by others and above
all those
most in need it is called
love and its path is to give ever more
of itself
today it is called american
patriotism born not of power
and privilege but of care for the common
good
with malice toward none and with charity
for all for our new president
we beg of you the wisdom solomon sought
when he knelt before you and prayed for
an understanding heart
so that i can govern your people and
know the difference
between right and wrong we trust in the
counsel of the letter of james
if any of you lacks wisdom you should
ask god who gives generously to all
without finding fault
and it will be given to you
pope francis has reminded us how
important it is
to dream together
by ourselves he wrote we risk seeing
mirages
things that are not there dreams on the
other hand
are built together
be with us holy mystery of love
as we dream together
help us under our new president to
reconcile the people of our land
restore our dream and invest it with
peace
and justice and the joy that is the
overflow
of love to the glory of your name
forever amen
ladies and gentlemen please remain
standing for the presentation of our
national colors
by the armed forces color guard the
singing of our national anthem
and for the pledge of allegiance
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen here for the
singing of our national anthem
accompanied by the president's own
united states marine band
please welcome lady gaga
so
thank you
uh
[Music]
[Music]
what's so probably
[Music]
and bright
[Music]
we watched
[Music]
[Music]
still
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
praise
[Applause]
all right
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome from
the city of south fulton georgia fire
and rescue department
president of the international
association of firefighters
local 3920 fire captain andrea m hall
for the reciting of the pledge of
allegiance
i pledge allegiance
to the flag of the united states
of america and to the republic
for which it stands one nation
under god indivisible
with liberty and justice for all
[Applause]
what you are all about to be part of
america
is a historic moment of firsts
to administer the oath to our first
african american our first asian
american and our first woman vice
president
kamala harris it is my great privilege
to welcome to the inaugural stage the
first latina
to ever serve on the supreme court of
the united states of america
justice sonia sotomayor
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen remain standing for
the oath of office followed by musical
honors
please raise your right hand and repeat
after me
i kamala davey harris do solemnly swear
baby harrison that i will support and
defend
the constitution of the united states
that i will support
and defend the constitution against
all enemies foreign against all enemies
that i will bear true faith and
allegiance to the city
that i will bear true faith and
allegiance to the same
that i take this obligation freely that
i take this obligation freely without
any mental reservation
or purpose of evasion without any mental
reservation
or purpose of evasion that i will well
and faithfully discharge that i will
well
and faithfully discharge the duties of
the office on which i am about to enter
the duties of the office upon which i am
about to enter
so help me god so help me god
[Music]
two two two
ladies and gentlemen please be seated
please welcome jennifer lopez to perform
this land as your land
and america the beautiful accompanied by
members of the president's own united
states marine band
[Applause]
[Music]
this land is your land
this land is my land
from california
to the new york islands
from the redwood floor
to the gulf stream waters
this land was made for you and
me as i went walking
down that ribbon of highway
i saw about me adding the skyway
i saw below me
at golden valley
this land was made for you and me
all this land oh
this land
[Music]
[Music]
this land was made for you and
me you and me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
see
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this land was made
for you and
[Music]
me
[Applause]
well that was great the sun is shining
and
mr president-elect this is the first
inauguration
in the history of america where jlo was
the warm-up
act for chief justice roberts with that
it is now my distinct honor
to introduce the chief justice of the
supreme court of the united states
john roberts to administer the
presidential oath
to the next president of the united
states
joseph r biden
ladies and gentlemen please stand for
the oath of office followed by musical
honors
um
please raise your right hand and repeat
after me
i joseph robinette biden jr do solemnly
swear
hi joseph robinette biden jr do solemnly
swear
that i will faithfully execute that i
will faithfully execute
the office of president of the united
states office of president of the united
states
and will to the best of my ability will
preserve protect and defend preserve
protect and defend
the constitution of the united states
constitution of the united states
so help you god so help me god
congratulations mr president
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
ladies and gentlemen please be seated
so
okay
my fellow americans a moment
we have all been waiting for
it is now my great privilege
and high honor to be the first person
to officially introduce the 46th
president of the united states joseph
r biden jr
[Applause]
chief justice roberts
vice president harris
speaker pelosi leader schumer
lyndon mcconnell vice president pence
my distinguished guest my fellow
americans
this is america's day
this is democracy's day a day of history
and hope
of renewal and resolve through a
crucible
for the ages america has been tested
anew
and america has risen to the challenge
today we celebrate the triumph not of a
candidate
but of a cause the cause of democracy
the people the will of the people
has been heard and the will of the
people has been heeded
we've learned again that democracy is
precious
democracy is fragile and at this hour my
friends
democracy has prevailed
so now on this hallowed ground we're
just a few days ago
violence sought to shake the capital's
very foundation
we come together as one nation under god
indivisible to carry out the peaceful
transfer of power as we have for more
than two centuries
as we look ahead in our uniquely
american way
restless bold optimistic
and set our sights on the nation we know
we can be
and we must be i thank my predecessors
of both parties
for their presence here today i thank
them from the bottom of my heart
and i know
and i know the resilience of our
constitution
and the strength the strength of our
nation
as does president carter who i spoke
with last night who cannot be with us
today
but whom we salute for his lifetime in
service
i've just taken the sacred oath each of
those patriots
have taken the oath first sworn
by george washington but the american
story
depends not on any one of us not on some
of us
but on all of us on we
the people who seek a more perfect union
this is a great nation we are good
people
and over the centuries through storm and
strife
in peace and in war we've come so far
but we still have far to go
we'll press forward with speed and
urgency for we have much to do
in this winter of peril and significant
possibilities
much to repair much to restore
much to heal much to build and much to
gain
few people in our nation's history have
been more challenged
or found a time more challenging or
difficult
than the time we're in now once in a
century virus
that silently stalks the country has
taken as many lives in one year
as america lost in all of world
war ii millions of jobs have been lost
hundreds of thousands of businesses
closed
a cry for racial justice some 400 years
in the making
moves us the dream of justice for all
will be deferred no longer
a cry for survival comes from planet
itself
a cry that can't be any more desperate
or any more clear and now
a rise of political extremism white
supremacy
domestic terrorism that we must confront
and we will defeat
to overcome these challenges to restore
the soul
and secure the future of america
requires so much more than words
requires the most elusive of all things
in a democracy
unity unity in another january
on new year's day in 1863
abraham lincoln signed the emancipation
proclamation
when he put pen to paper the president
said and i quote
if my name ever goes down into history
it'll be for this act and my whole
soul is in it
my whole soul is in it today
on this january day my whole soul is in
this
bringing america together uniting our
people
united in our nation and i ask every
american to join me
in this cause
uniting to fight the foes we face
anger resentment and hatred extremism
lawlessness violence disease
joblessness and hopelessness with unity
we can do great things important things
we can right wrongs we can put people to
work in good jobs
we can teach our children in safe
schools we can overcome the deadly virus
we can reward reward work and rebuild
the middle class and make health care
secure for all
we can deliver racial justice and we can
make america once again
the leading force for good in the world
i know speaking of unity can sound to
some like a foolish fantasy these days
i know the forces that divide us are
deep and they are real
but i also know they are not new
our history has been a constant struggle
between the american ideal that we're
all are created equal
and the harsh ugly reality that racism
nativism fear demonization
have long torn us apart
the battle is perennial and victory is
never assured
through civil war the great depression
world war 9 11
through struggle sacrifice and setbacks
our better angels
have always prevailed in each of these
moments
enough of us enough of us have come
together
to carry all of us forward and we can do
that now
history faith and reason show the way
the way of unity we can see each other
not as adversaries but as neighbors
we can treat each other with dignity and
respect we can join forces
stop the shouting and lower the
temperature
for without unity there is no peace
only bitterness and fury no progress
only exhausting outrage
no nation only a state of chaos
this is our historic moment of crisis
and challenge
and unity is the path forward
and we must meet this moment as the
united
states of america if we do that
i guarantee you we will not fail we have
never
ever ever ever failed in america
we've acted together and so today
at this time in this place let's start
afresh
all of us let's begin to listen to one
another again
hear one another see one another
show respect to one another politics
doesn't have to be a raging fire
destroying everything in his path
every disagreement doesn't have to be a
cause for total war
and we must reject the culture in which
facts themselves
are manipulated and even manufacturing
my fellow americans we have to be
different than this
america has to be better than this and i
believe america is so much better than
this just look around
here we stand in the shadow of the
capital dome as was mentioned earlier
completed amid the civil war
when the union itself was literally
hanging in the balance
yet we endured we prevailed
here we stand looking out on the great
mall
where dr king spoke of his dream here we
stand we're 108 years ago
at another inaugural thousands of
protesters tried to block
brave women marching for the right to
vote
and today we mark the swearing-in of the
first woman in american history elected
to national office
vice president kamala harris don't tell
me things can't change
can we stand across the potomac from
arlington cemetery
where heroes who gave the last full
measure of devotion
rest in eternal peace and here we stand
just days after a rioter's mom thought
they could use violence to silence the
will of the people
to stop the work of our democracy to
drive us from this sacred ground
it did not happen it will never happen
not today not tomorrow not ever
not ever
[Applause]
all those who supported our campaign
i'm humbled by the faith you've placed
in us to all those who did not support
us let me say this
hear me out as we move forward take a
measure of me and my heart
if you still disagree so be it
that's democracy that's america
the right to dissent peaceably than the
guard rails of our republic is perhaps
this nation's
greatest strength yet hear me clearly
this agreement must not lead to disunion
and i pledge this to you i will be a
president for
all americans all americans
and i promise you i will fight as hard
for those who did not support me
as for those who did
[Applause]
many centuries ago saint augustine
a saint of my church wrote that a people
was a multitude
defined by the common objects of their
love
defined by the common objects of their
love
what are the common objects we as
americans love
that define us as americans i think we
know
opportunity security
liberty dignity respect honor
and yes the truth
recent weeks and months have taught us a
painful lesson
there is truth and there are lies
lies toll for power and for profit
and each of us has a duty and a
responsibility
as citizens as americans especially as
leaders
leaders who have pledged to honor our
constitution
and protect our nation to defend the
truth
and defeat the lies look
i understand that many of my fellow
americans view the future
with fear and trepidation i understand
they worry about their jobs
i understand like my dad they lay a bed
wondering can i keep my health care
can i pay my mortgage thinking about
their families
about what comes next i promise you i
get it
but the answer is not to turn inward to
retreat into competing factions
distrusting those who don't look like
look like you
or worship the way you do or don't get
their news from the same sources you do
we must end this uncivil war
that pits red against blue
rural versus ireland or rural versus
urban
conservative versus liberal we can do
this
if we open our souls instead of
hardening our hearts
if we show a little tolerance and
humility
and if we're willing to stand in the
other person's shoes as my mom would say
just for a moment stand in their shoes
because here's the thing about life
there's no accounting for what fate will
deal you
days when you need a hand
there are other days when we're called
to lend a hand
that's how it has to be it's what we do
for one another
and if we are this way our country will
be stronger
more prosperous more ready for the
future
and we can still disagree my fellow
americans
and the work ahead of us we're going to
need each other
we need all our strength to preser to
persevere
through this dark winter we're entering
what may be the toughest and deadliest
period of the virus
we must set aside politics and finally
face this pandemic
as one nation
one nation and i promise you this
as the bible says weepy may endure for a
night
but joy cometh in the morning we will
get through this together together
look folks all my colleagues i serve
with
in the house and the senate up here
we all understand the world is watching
watching all of us today so here's my
message to those beyond our borders
america has been tested and we've come
out stronger for it
we will repair our alliances and engage
with the world once again
not to meet yesterday's challenges but
today's and tomorrow's challenges
and will lead not merely by the example
of our power but by the power of our
example
we'll be a strong and trusted partner
for peace
progress and security
look you all know we've been through so
much in this nation
and my first act as president i'd like
to ask you to join me
in a moment of silent prayer remember
all
those who we lost this past year to the
pandemic
those four hundred thousand fellow
americans moms dads husbands wives sons
daughters
friends neighbors and co-workers we'll
honor them
by becoming the people and the nation we
know we can
and should be so i ask you
let's say a silent prayer for those
who've lost their lives and those left
behind
and for our country
amen folks
this is a time of testing we face an
attack under democracy
and on truth a raging virus
growing inequity a sting of systemic
racism
a climate in crisis america's role in
the world
any one of these would be enough to
challenge us in profound ways
but the fact is we face them all at once
presenting this nation with the one of
the greatest responsibilities we've had
now we're going to be tested are we
going to step up
all of us it's time for boldness
for there's so much to do and this is
certain
i promise you we will be judged
you and i by how we resolve these
cascading crises of our era
we will rise to the occasion is the
question will we master
this rare and difficult hour when we
meet our obligations and pass along
a new and better world to our children i
believe we must i'm sure you do as well
i believe we will and when we do
we'll write the next great chapter in
the history of the united states of
america
the american story a story
that might sound something like a song
that means a lot to me
it's called american anthem
there's one verse that stands out
at least for me and it goes like this
the work and prayers of century have
brought us to this day
what shall be our legacy what will our
children say
let me know in my heart when my days are
through
america america i gave my best to you
let's add let's us add our own work and
prayers
to the unfolding story of our great
nation
if we do this then when our days are
through
our children and our children's children
will save us
they gave their best they did their duty
they healed the broken land
my fellow americans i closed the day
where i began
with the sacred oath before god and all
of you i give you my word
i will always level with you i will
defend the constitution
i'll defend our democracy i'll defend
america
and i'll give all all of you
keep everything you i do in your service
thinking not of power but of
possibilities not a personal interest
but the public good and together
we shall write an american story
of hope not fear of unity not division
of light
not darkness a story of decency and
dignity
love and healing greatness and goodness
may this be the story that guides us the
story that inspires us
and the story that tells ages yet to
come
that we answer the call of history we
met the moment
democracy and hope truth and justice
did not die in our watch but thrive
that america secured liberty at home and
stood once again as a beacon to the
world
that is what we owe our four bearers one
another
and generation to follow so
with purpose and resolve we turn to
those tasks
of our time sustained by faith
driven by conviction devoted to one
another and the country we love
with all our hearts may god bless
america
and may god protect our troops thank you
america
ladies and gentlemen please be seated
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
garth brooks to perform
amazing grace
[Music]
wow
[Music]
um
how sweet the
sound then
saved
[Music]
lost
[Music]
but now i
see
when we've been
there ten thousand
years bright shine
knees as the
sun
we've known lesson days
to sing god's praise
then when we
first begun
if i can ask you to sing this last verse
with me not just the people here
but the people at home who work as one
united uh
[Music]
like me
i once was lost
but now i'm
found was blind
but now i
see
it's okay
[Music]
[Applause]
hard not to be reminded of president
obama's singing that same song at the
mother emanuel
church
a song that in our culture is as close
to both poetry and prayer
as you could possibly come and we're
going to finish
with those two things let me introduce
amanda gorman
our nation's first ever national poet
laureate
[Applause]
[Music]
mr president dr biden
madam vice president mr
imhoth americans and
the world when day comes we ask
ourselves where can we find light in
this
never-ending shade the loss
we carry a sea we must wade we've braved
the belly of the beast
we've learned that quiet isn't always
peace and the norms and notions of what
just is isn't always
just this and yet
the dawn is hours before we knew it
somehow we do it somehow we've weathered
and witnessed a nation that
isn't broken but simply
unfinished we the successors of a
country
and a time where a skinny black girl
descended from slaves and raised by a
single mother
can dream of becoming president
only to find herself reciting for one
and yes we are far from polished
far from pristine but that doesn't mean
we are striving to form a union that is
perfect we are striving to
forge or union with purpose
to compose a country committed to all
cultures colors characters
and conditions of man and so we lift our
gazes not to what stands
between us but what stands before us
we close the divide because we know to
put our future first
we must first put our differences aside
we
lay down our arms so we can reach out
our arms to one
another we seek harm to none and harmony
for all let the globe if nothing else
say this is true
that even as we grieved we grew that
even as we hurt
we hoped that even as we tired we tried
that we'll forever be
tied together victorious not because we
will never again
know defeat but because we will never
again
sow division scripture tells us to
envision that
everyone shall sit under their own vine
and fig
tree and no one shall make them afraid
if we're to live up to our own time then
victory won't lie in the blade but in
all the bridges
we've made that is the promise to glade
the
hill we climb if only we dare it's
because
being american is more than a pride
we inherit it's the past we step into
and how we repair it we've seen a forest
that would
shatter our nation rather than share it
would destroy our country if it meant
delaying
democracy and this effort very nearly
succeeded but while democracy can be
periodically delayed it can never
be permanently defeated in this truth
and this faith we trust for while we
have our eyes on the future
history has its eyes on us
this is the era of just redemption we
feared it at
its inception we did not feel prepared
to be the heirs of such a terrifying
hour but within it we found the power to
author
a new chapter to offer hope and laughter
to ourselves so
while once we asked how could we
possibly prevail over catastrophe
now we assert how could catastrophe
possibly prevail over us we will not
march back to
what was but move to what shall be a
country that is bruised but
whole benevolent but bold fierce
and free we will not be turned around or
interrupted by intimidation because we
know
our inaction and inertia will be the
inheritance
of the next generation our blunders
become
their burdens but one thing is certain
if we merge mercy with mites and
mites with rights then love
becomes our legacy and change
our children's birthright so let us
leave behind a country better than one
we were left with
every breath from our bronze pounded
chest we will raise this wounded world
into a wondrous one we will rise from
the gold-limbed hills
of the west we will rise from the wind
swept northeast where our forefathers
first realized revolution we will
rise from the lake rim cities of the
midwestern states we will rise from the
sun baked south we will rebuild
reconcile and recover and every known
nook
of our nation in every corner called our
country
our people diverse and beautiful will
emerge
battered and beautiful when day comes we
step
out of the shade aflame and unafraid the
new dawn blooms
as we free it for there is always light
if only we're brave enough to see it if
only we're brave enough to be it
[Applause]
thank you amanda gorman now for our
benediction i'm pleased to introduce
reverend dr sylvester beeman the pastor
of the bethel
african methodist episcopal church in
wilmington delaware
a friend of president biden for 30 years
so
as a nation and people of faith gathered
in this historical moment
let us unite in prayer
god we gather under the beauty of your
holiness
and the holiness of your beauty we seek
your face
your smile your warm embrace
we petition you once more in this
celebration
we pray for divine favor upon our
president
joseph r biden and our first lady
dr jill biden and their family
we further asked that you would extend
the same
favor upon our vice president
kamala d harris and our second gentleman
doug imhoff and their family
more than ever more than ever
they in our nation need you
we need you for in you we discover
our common humanity in our common
humanity
we will seek out the wounded and bind
their wounds
we will seek healing for those who are
sick and diseased
we will mourn our dead we will befriend
the lonely the least and the left out
we will share our abundance with those
who are hungry
we will do justly to the oppressed
acknowledge sin and seek forgiveness
thus grasping reconciliation
in discovering our humanity
we will seek the good in and for all
our neighbors we will love the unlovable
remove the stigma of the so-called
untouchables
we will care for our most vulnerable our
children
the elderly emotionally challenged and
the poor
we will seek rehabilitation beyond
correction
we'll extend opportunity to those locked
out of opportunity
we will make friends of our enemies
we will make friends
of our enemies people your people
shall no longer raise up weapons against
one another
we will rather use our resources for the
national good
and become a beacon of life and good
will to the world
and neither shall we learn hatred
anymore we'll lie down in peace
and not make our neighbors afraid in you
oh god we discover our humanity
in our humanity we discover our
commonness
beyond the difference of color creed
origin
political party ideology geography
and personal preferences will become
greater stewards of your environment
preserving the land reaping from it a
sustainable harvest
and securing its wonder and
miracle-giving power
for generations to come this
is our benediction that from
these hallowed grounds
where slaves labor to build this shrine
and citadel
to liberty and democracy let us all
acknowledge
from the indigenous native american
to those who recently received their
citizenship
from the african-american to those whose
four parents came from europe
and every corner of the globe from the
wealthy to those
struggling to make it from every human
being regardless of their choices
that this is our country
as such teachers oh god as such
teach us oh god to live in it
love in it be healed in it
and reconcile to one another in it
lest we miss kingdom's goal
to your glory majesty
dominion and power forever
hallelujah glory
hallelujah and the strong name of our
collective faith
amen
please remain standing as the armed
forces color guard retires our national
colors
[Music]
do
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please be seated
and remain in your seats while the
president and official party depart the
platform
for safety reasons your ushers will
release your section in an organized
manner
following the playing of our national
march the stars and stripes forever
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh okay
thank you all thank you
[Music]
here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello thank you thank you
[Music]
congratulations thank you all thank you
very much thank you
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
watching
[Music]
so
they'll come back up here okay
remember you should develop
so
[Music]
we're going to cut this right here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
i
okay
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
thank you
[Music]
you're doing great
so
[Music]
everybody's good all right
wash your back
oh
so
oh
by the way
[Music]
okay all right
congratulations
okay
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
all right
are you still going to work on africa
you're welcome
[Music]
to work with me
hanging in there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
everybody
uh
dudes
[Music]
[Music]
my
my
okay
music was great
my
oh
i'd be the cemetery
uh
foreign
all right
uh
um
hey great work guys
best forward
come here
is
yeah sorry
now
now
[Music]
foreign
president oh
here
okay
[Music]
oh